Information that we have available is that on
some processor pu, the queue contains a task
tx. On another processor, pv, the queue contains
four threads. Tm, tq, tr, and tn, so
these are these are the threads on pv's
queue. And there's a particular thread, Ty, the
affinity of Ty with respect to Pu, is
2. This is the intervening thread index, and
I mentioned to you that the smaller the
index, the higher the affinity. So PuI for Ty
is two, and similarly Pu, PvI For T
y is one. There's a number of intervening tasks
that have run on the process of P u and P v respectively since the last time
T y had a chance to run on these
processes. And the scheduling policy we're going to pick
is the minimum intervening plus q. Minimum intervening plus
q, that's a scheduling policy that we're going to pick.
So, given that this is a scheduling policy, when
we decide at the point that Qi gets to run
again, when it is ready to be put on a Q, which Q will I put Ty on, if
the scheduling policy is minimum intervening plus Q? Is
it Pu's Q or is Pv's Q those are the
two choices available to you.